how are you doing today sir
awesome thanks steve thanks for having
me on oh please i've been uh wanting to
talk to you for a long time i'm glad it
worked out
good seriously um i have a bunch of
questions uh okay on a ton of subjects
and let's see how this goes i'll see if
you okay me at the end i'm joking it's
not that hard
if you have produced an awful lot of
things okay if someone has never seen
anything you've produced television
movies whatever it may be what do you
want them to watch first
in today's time i would want them to
watch the movie
eight mile
the television show friday night lights
and then
apollo 13.
these are all excellent choices um if
you could get and i don't know if this
question applies to you because
you can probably get the the financing
to make anything but maybe there's
something that's felt that you couldn't
if you could get the financing to make
anything you want what would you make
and why
um
[Music]
what would i make and why
i would
i like stories that are about science
like we have a move we have a project
called the seven eaves
and the why is it enlightening as to
what
it's a female empowerment vehicle
but it's enlightening to enter this new
world of
space
from this perspective
um i have a television project called
outliers with malcolm gladwell
and it celebrates greatness so i would
definitely want to be able to make that
and it's not easy to get anything
financed
um because you it
all things that i've ever made have been
incredibly difficult
um you know after the movie splash which
was successful i thought wow this is a
threshold in my life that everything
will be super easy until i made the
second movie which was called real
genius about genius kids that go to cal
tech oh i oh i'm aware of that movie
yeah
you're one of those super nerds that
followed it right please uh i later in i
was gonna i was gonna bring up with you
i love real genius and i love spies like
us and you made both yes
wow i love your filmography i love spies
i guess too it was hilarious why
wouldn't you love spies like a doctor
doctor doctor doctor
i like when when characters
that you believe in get duped and so
therefore in the case of chevy chase and
diana eckroyd they think they're you
know super smart they think they're
fully qualified to be in the secret
service in any way and they realize
they've just they don't even realize it
for a long time that they were duped
they just are operating
as duped agents
and so that's funny i like people that
are trapped in over their head and have
to
recognize
their limitation the limitations have
been put upon them and get through those
obstacles
so
so being being duped is kind of a
perfect uh construction for that and
spies i guess is one of those
oh yeah and if anyone's watching this
who's never seen spies like us you
should watch it's very very funny
it's very funny super funny um so you
you mentioned i think a lot of people
don't realize how difficult it is to
produce um but what ended up being the
thing that really almost broke you to
get to to to get it made
um the movie american gangster nearly
broke me
with stuff that starred denzel
washington and russell crowe that ridley
scott ended up directing and why did it
end up almost breaking me because i was
deeply deeply deeply passionate about
this story of frank lucas that was
played by denzel
who was um
[Music]
you know really a small time
hustler in harlem
just trying to survive and get
respect
and it was he found pretty early on that
that was impossible to get respect
self-esteem
and i like when people have to fight for
self-respect
he
the bottom line on that is that the
studio is prepared to make it at a
certain number it's like over 100
million dollars
and then they decided they would without
telling anybody including denzel ruslan
myself that
um they were going to cancel it
so
as hard as it was to get it to the place
i had it with a director
and in the cast of
um of denzel
they shut it down
so then i decided wow this has happened
to me before on the movie splash for
example everybody just hated the idea of
doing a movie about a mermaid they then
thought it made absolutely no sense and
so i would go into like a state of
meditation for
weeks just to try to regain strength to
go back into the field to try to get
that movie made
in this case i thought i'm going to be
it was so i was so stunned the studio
said
do not ever mention
american or gangster
separately or together those are words
that can't ever be used at our studio
but we love you just try to adhere to
that
and it was kind of a strict warning by
the chairman of the studio
and i thought i'd okay i'll he i'll
abide by that
and
the next day i woke up and i thought i
can't abide by that i've been my psyche
my mind has been so fully impregnated
with this story that i can't let it go
so
really against them the system
i
rebuilt a new case that would star
denzel who agreed to stay with it and
then instead of a previous actor i went
and got russell crowe because i'd just
done
a couple of movies with him including a
beautiful mind
and
he said i'll do it um i'm not sure what
the character is but i'm in
and between denzel and russell
and the new director ridley scott they
agreed and so by recontextualization i
was able to overpower overcome those
obstacles and get the movie american
gangster made to the studios and my
satisfaction
um which of your films ended up going
through the biggest changes in the
editing room compared to what you
thought going in
biggest change a beautiful mind went
through
tremendous amount of change
so that one beautiful mind the most
apollo 13 the second
and eight mile the third
what's interesting is i would have all
for different reasons
oh completely not that's it all for
different reasons i was gonna say i
could dig down but i am curious you have
alternate cuts of say some of these
movies do you actually save any of these
alternate cuts for your like personal
library
or is it sort of like once the movie
comes out like whatever's out that's the
one i keep
well i do have alternate cuts on a movie
you might not i don't know if you know
called frost nixon oh i know
yeah
the debate between richard nixon and
robert frost
and so that we
by the end we they
it was asked to ask of us us
to do three different endings
so
i think that's a really good question
uh we obviously could only go with one
ending but we do have the other two
yes
that's so interesting i can make nfts
out of them i bet
everyone's making those out of
everything
out of everything maybe this
conversation
yeah
exactly um did you ever come close to
directing
yes i did on a movie that starred steve
martin and goldie hawn called house
sitter which was a story of that i had
that i wrote
based on letting michael keaton
spent the weekend
at my house in malibu
because when he left
everybody in the neighborhood started
buzzing about
they never saw him really they just
saw the results of him
and they all thought those results were
now brian grazer
and therefore
i was very much in controversy because
they misunderstood
that it wasn't they didn't realize it
wasn't me it was my friend
but there was a lot of irregular action
activity at the house and they thought
wow brian is doing so i don't want to go
into details brian's doing so and so and
so and so bottom line is i turn it into
a story it was very attractive at the
time
and i thought you know i'm going to try
to direct this
actually it was a function of steve
martin he was already in
and we couldn't
close at a leading lady
and he said
why don't we go with so and so goldie
and you direct it and we'll help you
and i thought wow smart actors are the
key to directing and so maybe i should
just do this but then i realized i
wasn't that interested in um
you know moving a lamp and a lampshade
for three hours and talking about the
lampshade and the dust and all the
positioning that takes place i
definitely just was interested in
storytelling and definitely interested
in those two actors it would have been a
joy to do it but uh that was that was
one of them
my last question before getting into
swagger um
what's the status of the splash we make
oh well we're still working on it
actually and um
there's the status is it's in progress
to be made how's that
sure um
jumping into swagger so i uh what was it
about this material that said i want to
do this i want to be involved
kevin durant
basically
when kevin durant who's one of the best
athletes in the world
said to me we saw each other in sicily
of all places
and we were on a on a boat and a friend
of mine for lunch a friend of mine's
boat and he came on
and
he was
probably a little shy because
that's kevin or contained controlled
and when he walked out he said hey can i
get your number and call you i said
absolutely
bottom line is he did call me which i
didn't expect and we ended up having
lunch
and he told me
about youth basketball which i didn't
know much about
and
and that was very interesting to me but
you i didn't realize that youth
basketball existed and it's important to
um being signed as a nba athlete really
and it's sort of the precursor of all of
that i always thought it was high school
itself but unfortunately the substitute
for high school is now if you're an
athlete and playing basketball it's
youth basketball in recreation centers
and that's how kevin durant grew up in
in maryland five miles from the u.s
capitol
in a rough tough neighborhood where he
played
uh you know disciplined himself to play
eight hours a day i suppose
basketball for as much as he could
to be excel and so while he was doing
that he said he told me about the long
game
and i said what does that mean in the
long game and he said my mother single
mother was like the most expert guardian
of me
because what would happen is
many of these
scouts would come in and watch these
kids play particularly kevin
and hoping to hoping to sign them to a
sneaker company like because the money
train exists starts very early in life
like 15 16 years old and that's
basically what our show is it's about
how the money change the money chain
begins
at that very young age and in these kids
very fragile mind is very quite
difficult for them to try to even
navigate what that means when
uh somebody from one of the great
sneaker companies comes and says hey why
don't you come with us and it's and it's
unregulated so
his i said how did your mom handle it he
said she played the long game she didn't
let many people meet me and she was able
to very very adeptly
weed out you know who was good who was
bad who was right and wrong for for to
match up with me and he said but i saw
other kids
unfortunately fall prey to very early on
to the short game we're just you take
the quick money and you go and it seldom
works that way
so
he had a mom that was very protective
that he dearly loved and trusted and
that was
extremely helpful to him which again is
part of this show
100
um when you when you got it made at
apple how much is the network or how
much is apple saying to you do you have
a three season plan do you have a five
season plan before they're willing to
let the first season get made
so apple is very clearly a very thorough
and precise company so however
in the case of their television shows i
think if they're they're they're quite
intuitive and they've had great success
with operating their intuition they
liked the show they liked the world and
they agreed to do a season
they wanted to know that we had
a vision for second and third and fourth
season but we didn't have to go into
great detail to jump through many hoops
and pitch them second year third year we
just recently pitched them the second
what the second year would look like and
they were i
believe they were really out of loved it
yeah i was going to ask you for they're
very user friend apple is very user
friendly to artists
and so
they're quite respectful of artists and
and uh i mean there's gigantically
successful in other areas and so with
this i think they trust the artists
that they pick and they give them
you know pretty much
you know a lot of freedom to make the
show they believe in
uh what's interesting is that um i this
has a lot of similarities to like friday
night lights which you also did in the
way that it pulls back the curtain on
what's really going on
yeah
i also i believe you guys are working on
another friday night lights um is that
still the case
we're still yes we're working on another
friday lights movie in del rio texas
on the port on a border town
and hope to be making that the beginning
of next year
and that will
lead us into a new series that takes
place
uh in a more recent time like now today
um
and so we're excited about it
can i ask do you have a director on that
movie and a show runner for the series
um
they're
they're two brothers called the
doubtless
and so they are the they're the writers
and to be the show writers
uh i i'm a big fan of that show i'm i
would watch a remake if you know what i
mean um so my last thing for you i'm
basically out of time and uh there's a
million questions but what are you
what's bubbling up for you guys at the
company in terms of what else are you
getting ready to make what what can you
tease fans
um
what can we tease fans um well we make a
show called langdon already
that's that's the prequel to the da
vinci code based on the character that
tom hanks played
um
were
i'm hoping to make a show
really really really hoping
to make a show
that i believe will materialize
because i hedge everything
on the north shore of oahu
because after the movie blue crush which
i made um
around the same time as friday night
lights and eight mile
it blue crush is a surf show a women's
girl empowerment
show
that
is really really interesting and today
you could make it cinematically quite
dynamic where at the time
we did the best we could to show what
the physics of the ocean looked like now
you can
absolutely capture that with all the
different types variety of cameras that
are available that have tremendous
flexibility to go in and out of the
water to follow
you know to follow the wave to follow
the the contour of the ocean that's
where waves are built so we're very
excited about this show
also you have drones you can just throw
a drone up there and get a great job we
can drone yeah exactly
um this this show is is different than
blue crush it's more of a
family crime drama
i have to stop there but believe me sir
plenty of other questions for the
hopefully the next time i get to talk to
you uh i really have watched your movies
my whole life so it's really cool to
talk to you